HMS dive comes into Vision
means protected encircled just like
those on board
it's just unbelievable the ship's slowly
pulling in you start to see people's
features you see the eagerness on their
faces to get to safety after 10 hours at
Sea finally just some Solace from what
has been the most horrifying time
Saudi Arabia has evacuated more people
from the violent chaos of Sudan than any
other country in the world
and as they approached yet the shores
gratitude overflows how are you feeling
I'm glad for good friends in Saudi
Arabia today I am an American yeah
it was a long journey out of cartoon
lots of craziness happening but you know
what the the Sudanese people themselves
were beautiful people if it hadn't been
to the Sudanese people helping us in
each Journey each step of the way it was
absolutely beautiful then to see our
friends and brothers in Saudi Arabia get
us here I'm particularly grateful
foreign
can you believe this one running out of
water children inside
so but then we we got the chance to be
here
is that it's a heaven
final moments of disarray before their
feet hit steady ground and as the crowd
parts
that's my uncle really
[Music]
panic
Saudi Arabia's Navy has been commended
for its rescue efforts how much
resources have you thrown Behind These
evacuation missions we
used all of our resources and we don't
feel really we feel happy about this
wooden fields or we feel happy and we
are ready to provide whatever we can to
complete this operations do you see more
evacuation missions in the future to
help sum these people who are stranded
as a number already we didn't have exact
figures but we are ready to verify the
company
[Music]
around 2 500 people from 67 countries
have made it to safety here men and
women old and young out of the
devastation bet many still far from home
Sky News